[Music]
all right well my name is Jim McLaughlin
we're I'm a US national chess master
we're going to cover tactics for this
class lasts about an hour and we're
going to focus on the pinning idea you
pin a piece it can't move you attack it
with hopefully with a pawn or other
pieces and and hopefully you win it so
that's the basic idea okay we're going
to start with some fairly simple
examples but for the experienced players
that should get more interesting later
on this first example you can see it's
white to move and you should notice
right away that the Black Knight and the
black King are on the same file for
efile so it's simple white only has one
piece that could possibly pin anything
that rook so the key move is rook to e1
pinning the night the night can't move
or it would be check on the King so then
I can't move you have to protect it the
King can't protect it so the only move
for black is to move is pawn up two
squares and protect the pawn so one
reason pinning is such a good attacking
method is that it immobilizes the pin
piece so the knight on e4 can't move
once you get a piece that's immobilized
it's easier to attack it with pawns or
other pieces now to win the piece you
have to attack it
it's defended once so you have to take
it at least twice and fortunately in
this example we have a handy pawn on d2
that can move up one Square and attack
the knight the knight can't move so the
knight is lost and white wins
so this is the basic idea of a pins hi
the kick knight can't move because it's
check we wouldn't a knight and we win
the game good point I hadn't thought of
that I overlooked simple things like
that sometimes okay so I will go on to
the next example
well I wanted to mention all these
examples are taken from a chess book by
a German Sigmund tarish he wrote a chess
book called the game of chess he has
great examples in there on how to do
different tactics he has a whole section
on pinning these are all taken from that
book was written back in 1935 he sigmat
Tarrasch was a contender for the World
Championship he played a manual Laster
and a magic but he didn't win he lost
the match but anyway he was a very good
player okay so this is the second
example I know my experienced players
can see the pin right off the bat do any
of the young boys see how to pin a piece
here what would the move be right so the
knight the thing to look is you see the
night in the King or on that black
diagonal that means if we happen to have
a bishop that's on a black square which
we do we can move the bishop and pin the
knight now there's only one move to
protect the knight again what would be
that move
right and now remember once you pin it
you look to see if you have another
piece or pawn that can attack it so do
you see a pawn that can attack the
knight and what would the move be f4
very good very good so once again a
simple example but this time it was a
diagonal pin the other pin was on a file
by rook now a bishop most pins are done
by bishops and rooks
and sometimes the Queen but the most
effective ones are by bishops and rooks
so there's no way to save the piece
white wins the game okay now we should
get a little more complicated idea this
position doesn't have a pin immediately
and it requires an inaccurate mover to
buy black so we'll just move into it
well white moves the rook over to the D
black moves the rook over to attack the
pawn and to keep it from advancing to
get a queen and the knight attacks of
the pawn now
white moves the rook over to the D file
to attack the knight and he sets us a
little trap for black and because this
is an example on pinning black falls
right into the trap and makes a double
question mark or a very bad move and he
takes that pawn on e5 who sees the pin
now what's the move
how no it's a the rook is on the first
row see the one and these are the files
which file does it go to to pin the
knight right rook to e1 so it just moves
over one square
notice that the knight
if the knight could move and check the
king he could get out of the pin but
there's the Kings on a white square the
Knights on a black square meaning the
knight has to move to a white square so
right off the bat you could know that he
can't check the King because he's moving
to the same same color as the King and
there would be no check also the
important thing is the King can't move
up and protect the night.the and the
other thing is the knight can't move and
protect the rook because the rook is on
a white square and again the knight
moves to white square but the author
points out want you to imagine this in
your head let's see oh if if the black
rook was on e6 the white square in front
of the knight would that save black is
there a move that would say black in
that case now I would expect my more
advanced students to say yay or nay
can't assume that that rook on EI tis on
e6 right in front of the night okay so
it's on the white square in front of the
night you got that does can black save
the game or not are you sure
yeah but look the knight counter-attacks
what is the knight attacking the bishop
and is that the bishop with Czech and
from f4 it would get the rook on e6
wouldn't it so cute little subtle point
so actually if the Rick was on e6 black
could save the day by moving his knight
back and white would have nothing better
than the retreat as bishop and protect
his rook so that's an interesting little
nugget in tactics but okay so that's the
kind of thing you have to look for all
right yeah so the knight would retreat
to g6 and see how the text of the bishop
on f4 or using this arrow the knight
would retreat here to the white square
two scores in front of the King g6 and
it would attack the bishop and notice
that it takes the bishop with check
gaining a move to take the the white
rook which would have taken the black
rook when the knight moved rook takes
rook on e6 you see that then Knight
takes bishop check the King moves and
the knight moves back to e6 and takes
the rook and actually that would win for
black because of that the best move for
white is to give up trying to win
anything retreat his bishop and try to
hold an endgame a pawn down then he
might do it with a bishop versus the
night sometimes those are draws okay
let's go to the next example obviously
this is more complicated there's quite a
number of pieces there's a rook a queen
and a minor piece of bishop for white a
knight for black and eat let's see white
how many pawns does white have
and how many does black have other
things being equal than whites upon up
right okay but it in this case it
doesn't mean that much because number
one see how it's a double pawn and
double pawns are usually weak but this
game doesn't depend on the pawn play
anyway remember in the last example we
had the other side make a really bad
move it's White's turn to make a really
bad move here notice that black why it's
blacks move black takes that pawn on e5
and see how the Black Knight threatens
the Queen on f7 not to mention the fact
on g4 that's right now the safe move
what would be the safe move for white in
this position who would like to make a
guess about that notice there's a pawn
hanging on c7 the Queen could take the
pawn on c7 and threaten Queen takes for
a checkmate that looks pretty strong but
that's not the safe move who sees the
safe move for white what is it yeah
that's basically what the author says to
protect the bishop and those weak white
squares around the King because the
Queen and Knight are threatening to come
in on f3 if the Queen moves off could be
very dangerous so you're right I think
the author said like Queen to f4 because
then he would threaten to trade Queens
and attack the knight at the same time
but the same idea okay but white
blunders here and takes the pawn he
thinks he likes that checkmate threat
and he's attacking the
Johnny Five you see that it's a double
attack but he abandoned his kingside
didn't he so what's the winning move for
black okay
f 3 check okay you're right
notice that the queen is checking the
king and attacking the bishop that's
another theme of tactics which is
covered later in the book double attack
but it rises here there's only one way
to save the bishop what's the move for
white no the king is in check either has
to move the King our block put a piece
between the Queen and the king okay
you're right now white is still
threatening Queen takes rook check right
so we need to move the rook and we move
the rook and make a threat at the same
time what move would that be
don't forget our nights hanging if we
don't make a threat with the RIC will is
the knight
I guess we could do rook to e8 and
protect the knight but there's a better
move than that rook to f8 is the right
move
look the the bishop is pinned that's our
theme right remember when you have a pin
piece you want to attack it with another
piece or pawn and the piece we can
attack it is the rook and the threat is
Queen takes bishop checkmate
obviously white doesn't have time to
take the knight does white white has to
protect the bishop to prevent checkmate
there's only one move what's that move
can right now remember I said when you
have a pin piece you try to attack it
with all your pieces and pawns what is
the way to attack it with another piece
what's the move for black
what is it Knight to g4 absolutely
correct
notice that the Queen conveniently
protects the rook so if there's nothing
there this rook the white work is on b1
and it's blocked by pawns so the white
work cannot protect the bishop there's
no defense the next move is Knight takes
bishop and probably followed by
checkmate soon after that so that's this
is a good example on how strong pins are
let's go on to the next example again
it's not immediately apparent where the
pin is in this position so we have to
make a couple moves to go into it the
first move is rook a to d1 notice now
the crook and Queen are lined up and see
there's a black queen behind the pawn if
the King wasn't protecting the Queen we
would have a good move based on pinning
that pawn what would that move B can
write so rook to d1 you see that's what
we call pressure there's pressure down
that D file by the Queen and rook it's
attacking and pinning that pawn now it
is protected by the bishop but
nevertheless if you don't have a better
way to go you increase the pressure on
your opponent which what rook a to d1 is
the best move now to show the example
the pin our author has black make a
horrible move black wants to castle to
connect his rooks usually a good idea
but not in this case who sees the
winning move one of the young gentlemen
do you see a good move for white
remember that pawns pin now if the pawns
pin it's not an effective protector what
does the pawn protect the bishop so if
the pawns not effective protector who
can take how can we take the bishop with
a piece the Queen what's that move give
me the notation Queen X right and notice
what happens if D takes e5 what's the
next move all right let me do that d2 e5
what's the winning move for white
right
see we won a whole bishop we gate well
you gave the Queen for the bishop we
took it but we got the Queen back
because the pawn was pin and the rook
can now with the line open the work
cannot take the Queen okay good
this one isn't the greatest example it's
very simple and again it depends on
black making a horrible move so let's go
right into it that's the horrible move
he's the author says black wants to
complete his development connect these
rooks
his next move will bring the rook on a 8
over 2 e 1 maybe to protect the pawn or
maybe he'll go to d8 and protect the
bishop that would be a strong position
but what is the drawback to Bishop to d7
who sees a good move for white and Oh
where's the pin there's a pin here
where's the pin who sees the pin g7
that's the pawn in front of the King
notice that the white bishop and the
black bishop are on the same diagonal is
there a piece or pawn between the two
bishops yes that is the the pawn that's
pinned if that pawn it moves then Bishop
takes Bishop right so what's the winning
while not winning but what's the best
move for white in this position d5 nxd5
and notice that if he takes d5 we get
the piece back and we won our pawn
utilizing the pin
now the reason I say this isn't such a
hot example notice that even after white
one a pond but black is still coupons a
hat so it's doubtful that white wins but
again it's just an example now let's see
oh this is easy there's a win for white
now when you look at a position for the
first time what you want to do what I do
I start with the pawn so first I look at
the white pawns and I see there seven of
them notice that six of them are almost
back at their starting squares and
there's only one advance pawn upon on e5
then look at the white knights I like to
work from the pawns to the Knights to
the bishop to the higher pieces the
works and the Queen so let's look at the
white knights or they don't seem to have
been developed yet not likely they're
going to factor into any kind of
tactical combination is there then let's
look at the bishops develop means
develop means you move the piece from
its beginning square usually into the
middle of the board so it can take key
central squares okay so that's what
develop means so the Knights are not
developed now let's look at the bishops
what they will later but at this point
in time the Knights have not moved right
what's your question
Bishop to g5 that's not a bad move but
there's a better move but let's continue
analyzing the position because that's
important
look at the white bishops one Bishop has
moved up one square to e2 not a bad
square but it's not attacking any black
pieces or pawns is it so that Bishop is
not likely to enter into our little
tactical combination is it alright now
obviously the rooks are hemmed in by
pawns and knights so you could roll the
Rick's out that leaves the black squared
Bishop on c1 that has something as you
pointed out it can move to g5 and attack
the Queen and well at least it can make
an attacking move right there are no
pawn moves for white to attack anything
now let's look at blacks position again
the pawns looks to me like there's seven
pawns
three in front of the King and four in
the Queen side so the pawns are the same
number on both sides aren't they note
that the black pawn on d7 blocks that
white square bishop apparently black
doesn't know how to develop his pieces
properly so the bishop can't get out the
white bishops can't get out he blocks
the rook now the Knights are pretty well
placed they're both in the center see
the knight on d5 and the knight on c6 so
I have no problem with them but I'm not
real fond of that black scored bishop
what does that black square bishop it
well that's an excellent idea
so that black square bishops not doing
anything for black all right now the
other point is blacks is castle that's
about it now let's find the winning move
what's the winning move what is it
and what's your threats Queen 2xg seven
checkmate that's pretty strong threat I
agree and notice that the pawn on e5
comes in handy it prevents the black
Queen from going to f6 where it could
defend g7 a pawn in the center advanced
to the fifth is a strong attacking pawn
it drives the defensive pieces away from
the King in fact I bet when white played
a five black moved his Knight from f6 to
d5 so not only does it deprive the Queen
it drove the night away from the defense
to the knight could have if it was on f6
it could have retreated to e8 and
protected g7 interesting little points
there's only one way to stop checkmate
what is it
it is g6 but there's a drawback to g6
fairly obvious that's right and and is
the rook worth more than the bishop or
is this bishop worth more than the rook
the pawn is worth 1 point the bishop and
Knights are three the castles are five
the queen is nine and the King isn't
valued because if you lose the King it's
check mate Nick game's over so they
don't value the King but interesting in
the ending when the Queen's and rooks
are gone
and the king doesn't have to worry about
being checkmated the king can move to
the middle of the board and support his
pawns moving up to get a queen and the
king because he can move one square in
any direction the King is stronger than
a knight or a bishop did you know that
yes so in the ending the King is an
attacking piece that's why they always
move it to the center of the board
turbed
the opposing pawns hopefully you can win
one and remember tactically you want to
win a pawn or a piece a pawn is usually
enough to win the game down to win upon
their piece you have to have at least
two pieces attacking it in a complicated
game you may need three pieces attacking
it because it can be defended more than
twice so the that's why you develop your
pieces so you can attack your opponent's
pawns and pieces with multiple pieces
not one or two and if you start moving
pawns you waste the opportunity to move
your pieces into play and you're going
to be attacked you're not going to be
attacking anybody okay well that's
enough for tonight
thanks for coming
[Music]
you